more on this now with the former chief
scientific adviser to the government Sir
David King he joins me now so David good
morning to you a significant day
yesterday the Prime Minister announcing
a further easing of lockdown perhaps
going farther than many had expected was
he right I think it's extraordinarily if
we take the long view we know that the
winter is a likely period when the virus
takes off again we must therefore aim to
completely get rid of the virus from
this country before the winter and if we
if we move too quickly which is what I
think is being proposed here the risk of
running into a second wave becomes very
significant we have done such a good job
in this country we the public in staying
at home if we could only be a little
more patient we we still see a thousand
at least new cases in this country and I
don't think there's anyone who can
believe from the scientific point of
view that this is a wise move we really
need to get the number of infections
down and we must have a find test trace
isolate and support system a fine system
means you find every new case a test
system means you test every new case
with the virus and isolate every one of
these must be properly isolated for two
weeks now that must be checked on and
secondly those who put into isolation
must be supported that system isn't
fully up and running yet the system
introduced by the government in I
believe was extremely clumsy my group
believes we should have been using local
authorities GPS etc to implement all of
that why not use that even now I would
encourage the government to spread the
use of capability in existing localities
but until we have all of that fully
operating this is extremely risky it's
like traveling in the
dark we don't know whether our reading
until it's too late
and we don't know been spreading but the
government has got to weigh up the
economic implications as well we've had
one of the longest lock downs the
infection rate is shrinking at between
two and four percent each day the our
number is below one how long can you
really feasibly expect people to stay at
home to stay away from work businesses
to be closed without causing even
greater damage in terms of the
development of this epidemic we went
into lockdown much later than every
other country except one or two where
the virus is taking off very crudely
right now the the reason it's taking us
longer to come out of lockdown is simply
because we had a much greater
infectivity rate in the population and
if we follow Germany and Spain and Italy
and coming out of lockdown too quickly
because we see them coming out of
lockdown we will see where we risk
severely seeing another way if I just
take for example Spain they came out of
lockdown when there were no deaths per
day for seven days in a row but that's
really a good measure of when you're
getting it under control we we are still
seeing a large number of weekly deaths
in this country and I'm afraid the signs
are that the infectivity rate in the
country may already even be going up so
I think there is a real problem and I
fully understand but from an economic
point of view as well we need to get
this pandemic over with as quickly as
possible the last thing to do is to risk
losing that David I'm conscious that we
are a bit of short of time and I do want
to get through a lot with you I'm
interested in your perspective as a
former chief scientific adviser looking
at that news conference yesterday the
prime minister standing there alongside
Patrick valance and Chris witty the body
language between them how comfortable do
you think the scientific advice
were with the moves announced yesterday
and what will have been going on behind
the scenes I don't believe there's any
difference of opinion on this issue
between independents age that I'm
currently chairing and the Sage Group
the sage scientists are themselves
signing Prime Minister went against the
will of his scientists this is
definitely a political decision and of
course in the end the scientists are
there to give advice and political
decisions are made but let me stress
again the economics point in exactly the
same way it's not as if the economists
should be saying come on guys stop they
lock down let's get back to business
without knowing that we can get this
under control
everyone must see that the sooner we get
it under control the sooner we get the
economy back up and running the sooner
we get schools officer shops restaurants
pubs etc open but I tell you what I'm
really worried about and this is what
every scientist is worried about around
the whole world ninety seven percent of
what's called super spreading events
occur indoors and if we're saying we're
going to open up restaurants and in
particular pubs I think that's where the
big risk lies because we all know two
things one is the pub's do get quite
crowded now they will try to keep to
even the one meter rule but as you as
the evening goes on and people get
happier and merrier we all know what
happens we all relax and one meter apart
is the distance the social distance
average that we stand up between each
other but when we're talking we use
people and when we use body language we
narrow that distance down there were
very firm warnings they were there from
the prime minister and the scientific
advisors yesterday that we really do
need to stick to the guidance it is two
metres wherever possible one meter plus
with mitigations can I ask you about the
different approaches though between the
different nations of the United Kingdom
they're all seeing the same science the
chief medical officer
that he was in constant contact with the
chief medical officers of Wales Scotland
and Northern Ireland so why are we
seeing these different approaches quite
simply different political decisions I'm
sure I don't I don't think that there's
a disagreement across the borders about
the the science and how risky it is to
change the strategy at this point in
time I mean one thing I can say is that
the the Prime Minister made very clear
statements about the fact that the
government is going to keep an eye on
whether or not this results in a super
spread event I need to worry it though
about the statement about localities in
other words if we say right in Liverpool
there's a super spread event there for
Liverpool goes back into lockdown I'm
afraid there is really it's difficult to
understand a local spread event in a
country where movement of people around
the country is happening in other words
it's likely that if it begins locally in
one part of the country it will spread
okay so David King thank you very much
indeed for your thoughts this morning
thank you